&gt;&gt; I know a 5 year old is considered to be a child, and so is a 2 year old. A
person who is 16 would be considered a teenager, and people for these last ages
would be considered adults. When checking to see if this is a function, I want
to make sure that my inputs correspond to exactly 1 output. In each case, I only
have one arrow leaving, or going away, towards the output. So yes, this is a
function. And remember, just like last case with Jill and Tim, who's outputs
were i, we have 5 and 2, who's outputs were both at child. We can havt two
inputs that make the same output, but we can't have two outputs from one input.
For the second relation I know the color red can correspond to a strawberry or
to a raspberry. Notice this input has 2 different outputs. If I say the word
red, I'm not sure what output I'm talking about. I could be talking about a
strawberry or a raspberry. I don't know. So this is definitely not a function.
It breaks our rule. This input has two outputs. We find the same case to be true
with yellow. It could correspond to a banana or a lemon. If an input has two
outputs even once, then it's not a function. So we only need to stop once we see
that the first time.